Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ja, also das Missbrauchsszenario von Clouds ist natürlich relativ hoch. Es ist halt eine sehr mächtige Infrastruktur und damit kann man auch Schindluder treiben.
Vor allem gerade weil es so eine anonyme Sache ist auch. Also es gibt ja niemand mehr, der irgendwie wo ich hingehen muss, irgendwie Bargeld auf den Tisch legen muss, vielleicht noch einen Ausweis zeigen muss oder sowas. Oder der irgendwie im schlimmsten Fall auch mal mit den Jungs, mit den Baseballkeulen bei mir vorbeikommen kann. Lass mich raten, man braucht Kreditkartendaten, um sowas zu mieten? Richtig. Ich habe eine Idee, wo die herkommen könnten. Okay, also man klaut sich einmal Kreditkartendaten aus dem Netz, setzt dann damit eine Cloud auf, macht dann irgendwie eine riesen Attacke. Genau, dann ist es auch nicht so schlimm, wenn die nach zwei Stunden gesperrt ist oder nach einer Stunde, weil dann hat man sein Ziel erreicht.
Und um die Szenarien eben einmal durchzugehen, das beginnt natürlich bei Mailservern, die Spam-Mail verschicken oder in irgendeiner Art und Weise Spam im Internet hinterlassen, also Spam-Kommentare in Blogs, Spam auf Spam-Accounts, auf Twitter, Facebook-Spams. Alles in dieser Größenordnung ist mit der Cloud sehr gut und in sehr hohem Maße umzusetzen. Das führt dazu, dass wenn man heute versucht, beispielsweise auf der Amazon-Cloud einen Mailserver zu betreiben, man schon mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit davon ausgehen kann, dass der bei vielen Anbietern geblacklisted ist. Also um das zu erklären, das ist so. Die Leute, die selber Mailserver betreiben, führen Listen von bösen Computern. Also von Computern, von denen erwarten sie, da kommt sowieso nur Müll raus. Deshalb lesen wir von dem aus Prinzip gar keine Mail.
Ich hätte beinahe gesagt, dass das so eine Art Bildzeitung ist.
Ja, und die Wahrscheinlichkeit heute, wenn ich mir irgendeinen beliebigen Server ziehe, dass sich dieser schon mal in einem Adressraum befunden hat, aus dem so viel Quatsch getrieben wurde, dass der von Anbietern auf schwarze Listen geschrieben wurde, ist relativ hoch. Satz war komplizierter.
Im Prinzip merken sich die E-Mail-Server draußen irgendwann, Cloud Computing von Amazon zum Beispiel, da kommt häufig Spam raus. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt einen neuen E-Mail-Rechner, also einen E-Mail-Server aufsetze, in der Amazon-Wolke und dann damit anfange, wilde E-Mails zu verschicken, könnte das viele Leute sagen, du bist doch einer von den Spammers. Kommt man irgendwie wieder raus, oder ist es dann einfach gelaufen?
Das ist echt schwer daraus zu kommen. Also im konkreten Fall Amazon ist der einfachste Weg, sich einfach einen neuen Server hochzufahren. Der kriegt eine neue Adresse und das so oft zu machen, bis man einen hat, der nicht mehr hat. Das ist tatsächlich das einfachste Szenario, um da rauszukommen. Aber das ist ja nur quasi der Missbrauch auf unterster Ebene. Das war ja quasi nur das Level, Hacker benutzen das genauso, wie sie in anderen Computer verwenden könnten, um Quatschstammel zu treiben. Darüber gibt es deutlich interessante...
Ich würde gerne noch mal dabei verweilen. Also wenn wir jetzt Spam-Mills, das ist nervig, aber nicht wirklich gefährlich. Wird das denn auch wirklich benutzt für Übernahmeangriffe, um Dinge zu hacken? Kann man damit mit dieser Größe an Rechenleistung, die auf Knopfdruck zur Verfügung steht, noch mehr treiben, außer Spam-Mills zu verschicken?
Genau, darauf wollte ich gerade kommen. Wir kommen ja die ganze Zeit von diesen... Das Passwort heute Abend ist ja Verschlüsselung. Also das heißt, bei diesen ganzen Backup-Diensten ging es ja darum, die Frage, wenn meine Daten sicher verschlüsselt sind, dann könnte man dem vertrauen. Nun ist ja ein Problem dieser Verschlüsselung. Man liest das ab und zu in der Zeitung. Die Vergleiche sind immer, um diese Datei zu knacken, um diesen Schlüssel zu knacken, müsste ein Computer so und so lange rechnen. Also beispielsweise 500 Jahre. Bis heute war jedem klar, na gut, keiner lässt seinen Computer 500 Jahre laufen, um diesen Schlüssel zu knacken. Und das stimmt natürlich. Trotzdem hab ich in der Cloud heute die Möglichkeit, einfach 5000 Computer zu betreiben. Und 5000 Computer brauchen dann natürlich nur noch ein Zehnteljahr, um diesen Schlüssel zu hacken. Und es gibt den ersten Dienst, der tatsächlich in der Cloud aktiv ist. Es gibt auf Amazon Web Services, ich weiß nicht, ob es sie immer noch gibt, aber einen Dienst, die anbieten, WPA-Schlüssel zu knacken. Genau. WPA gilt bislang als relativ sicher. Web ist quasi erschlagend gehackt. WPA gilt bislang noch als relativ sicher. Es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass die immense, also das ist ja egal, wie der Angriff läuft, sie kriegen diese Dinge mit einer relativ hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit geknackt. Ich glaube, es kostet 20 Dollar. Die muss man einfach überweisen und dann kann man einen WPA-Schlüssel knacken.
Wie funktioniert das? Man muss irgendwie ein bisschen wieder abhören, schickt den Traffic dahin oder was?
Genau, man braucht sehr wenige Pakete. Konkretes Angriffsszenario, ich bin in einer Wohnung, ich möchte in das Netzwerk meines Nachbarn einbrechen. Ich muss ein paar Pakete aufzeichnen, die da durch die Luft fliegen, das ist nicht sehr kompliziert. Und dann übersende ich diese Pakete und den Netzwerknamen an den Anbieter, überweise 20 Dollar und kriege, mit gewisser Wahrscheinlichkeit, den Schlüssel zurückgeschickt.
Das ist hochgradig illegal oder darf man das?
Das ist fürchterlich illegal.
Aber das macht den Betreibern von diesem Angebot nichts aus?
Deshalb bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es die noch gibt oder nicht.
Aber die gab es auf jeden Fall. Grundsätzlich einen Schlüssel zu knacken, ist jetzt erstmal nichts illegales. Der Anbieter kann auch sagen, schickt uns eine Datei und wir knacken die. Aber wir wissen natürlich nicht, dass es für das WPA Netzwerk von deinem Nachbarn ist. Ich schicke das hin und sage, ich habe den Schlüssel zu meinem eigenen WLAN vergessen. Könnt ihr den für mich rausfinden?
Ich glaube der professionelle Begriff dafür ist Password Recovery.
Also gibt es auch für ZIP-Files, für Passwortgeschützte, PDFs, für Word-Dokumenten und weiß nicht was alles. Und ich glaube, das gibt so einen Anbieter aus Osteuropa. Und ich vermute mal, dass der mittlerweile auch diesen Weg in die Cloud gegangen ist. Also es gibt da auch durchaus viele Szenarien, man könnte alles Mögliche an Verschlüsselung damit auch brechen. Das muss jetzt nicht der WPA-Schlüssel sein. Also das, was Nico auch schon gesagt hat, wie die IT-Leute sagen, sowas skaliert ganz gut. Das heißt also, ich kann es wirklich dann einfach in die Breite skalieren, sagen, okay, ich werfte halt jetzt nicht einen Rechner fünf Jahre, sondern einfach 5000 Rechner drauf. Und gated spielt jetzt erstmal auch keine Rolle. Und wahrscheinlich, wenn der Schlüssel dann auch irgendwie in der Woche geknackt ist, dann war es das gated ja noch wert.
Um es einmal noch zu sagen, weil es mir am Herzen liegt, also obedarf der Tatsache, ob das Knacken selber legal oder illegal ist, in das Netzwerk des Nachbarn einzubrechen, ist natürlich trotzdem auch gerade illegal.
Das wollte ich an dieser Stelle hören. Wenn es denn verschlüsselt ist und... Nur um darauf noch mal hinzuweisen. Dingens, jetzt haben wir so viele Rechner, jetzt bin ich ganz wirr im Kopf. Verschlüsselung, wenn man, also WPA funktioniert ist, wenn man irgendwie ein paar tausend Rechner raufwürfen, geht es halt sehr schnell. Gibt es denn eine Verschlüsselungsart, die dagegen immun ist? Also sagen die auch bei 5000 Rechnern sagt, den Finger zeigt und sagt nee? Also was ist mit PGP zum Beispiel? Oder GPG? Da sagen die am halb viersten. Na ja, es kommt auf die Verschlüsselung drauf an, die da verwendet wird. Und gut, man kann natürlich auch so Sachen machen wie noch ausprobieren und sowas. Das ist jetzt schwer zu sagen. Also weil natürlich auch die Leistung der Cloud wird ja auch immer größer. Und insofern wird die Sache denn nur teurer, aber dauert nicht länger. Also das ist, so kann man dann halt auch sagen. Hey, super beruhigend. Ja klar, also wenn Geld keine Rolle spielt, dann ziehe ich das Ganze einfach in die Breite und sag jetzt Rechner nicht mehr 10 Rechner, sondern 10.000 Rechner. Einfach alles, was Amazon und alle anderen Anbieter anzubieten hat. Wir nehmen alles. Wie teuer das wohl wäre. Einmal die ganze Rechenleistung aller Cloud Computer. So viel Kohle haben wir aber auf jeden Fall nicht, denke ich. Das kann man also für Unsinn, gibt es noch mehr Unsinn, die man damit treiben kann? Na ja, wenn man einen eigenen Server betreibt, dann sieht man schon, dass da ziemlich viele Angriffsversuche zumindestens auch von Amazon oder von anderen Cloud-Diensten auch ausgehen. Das heißt also, da wird dann probiert, nach fehlerhaften Softwareversionen auf dem Server zu suchen. Also man sieht es dann in irgendwelchen URLs, die man im Blog hat, irgendwelche Datenbank-Administrator-Geschichten oder irgendwelche anderen Zugänge, irgendwelche bekannten Sicherheitslücken im Content-Management-System von der Webseite. Es wird nach Passwörtern oder nach Zugängen mit zu einfachen Passwörtern gesucht, wo dann einfach gescannt wird, also einfach wild drauf los und wir gucken mal, ob irgendwo was gefunden wird. Und sowas wird tatsächlich auch ganz viel von diesen Cloud-Servern mittlerweile gemacht, dass man eigentlich, wenn man einen eigenen Server betreibt, mittlerweile diese IP-Adressen, diese Bereiche eigentlich sperren kann, weil da ist jetzt auch nicht so furchtbar viel Sinnvolles zu erwarten. Was ich mich jetzt frage ist, es ist also nicht teuer, also nicht derbeteuer, sich so ein Ding zu mieten. Das heißt, es lohnt sich wahrscheinlich ziemlich schnell. Gibt es da irgendwelche Statistiken? Habt ihr da irgendwas am Kopf, wo man sagen kann, das lohnt sich für die Leute, die damit Schindeludertreiben, einfach weil sie dann viel mehr Geld mit einnehmen, als so eine Cloud zu mieten kostet? Gibt es da Zahlen?
Nee, ich glaube nicht, dass die veröffentlicht werden.
Ja, aber es gibt ja meistens sozusagen Schätzungen irgendwie.
Nein, ich habe keine Schätzungen.
Nein, es kommt auch immer noch auf Anweisungen, was dir wert ist, einfach so einen Schlüssel zu knacken. Also für dich ist es wert, in ein bestimmtes WLAN reinzukommen. Die andere Sache ist natürlich, weil ich mir so vorstelle, die Cloud nutze ich und ich muss dafür zahlen, aber allerliebsten wäre es mir doch, ich muss gar nichts dafür zahlen. Ich übernehme einfach eine Cloud, die jemand anders gemietet hat. Wie mache ich das?
Also einmal, um sozusagen an der Stelle noch ein bisschen Werbung zu machen, weil du wolltest ja schon auf die Einbruchsszenarien, das gibt es an der Stelle. Es gibt Cloud-Ambieter, die es anbieten, die den Einstieg umsonst machen. Interessant ist da sicherlich im Moment die Google App Engine. Da kann ich bis zum gewissen Grad, kann ich anfangen, Cloud-Infrastrukturen auszuprobieren und muss dafür nicht bezahlen.
Also in einem Rahmen, der tatsächlich auch was bringt, oder?
Jaja, bis zu einem wahnsinnig hohen Rahmen, kann man sogar sagen. Also das heißt, alle normalen Webseiten kann man dort quasi für umsonst betreiben. Und wenn man nicht gerade eine gigantische Webseite ist, das Problem ist, dass die Entwicklungsoberfläche, auf der man das betreiben muss, nicht sehr üblich ist. Also dort läuft kein normales Blogsystem. Es ist eine Python, es geht zu weit ins Detail. Man muss sich damit auseinandersetzen, aber es ist interessant, damit einmal rumzuspielen und einen sehr innovativen und anderen Ansatz, dieses Cloud Computing anzugehen, worauf du aber schon wieder hinaus wolltest, war natürlich schön kluter.
Jetzt bin ich der Böse hier.
Während wir davor darüber gesprochen haben, wie man mit der Cloud nach außen Mist machen kann, gibt es natürlich noch die interessante Frage, ob es Angriffsszenarien auf die Cloud gibt. Und die gibt es natürlich. Und diese sind auch sehr interessant, weil auf unserem Notizzettel für die heutige Sendung steht...
Hach, halt, halt, halt. Wir hören jetzt eine Musik, dann machen wir Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und dann sagst du, wie das mit den Angriffen auf die Cloud funktioniert.
Denn sie ist wieder da.
Eine Karte für 10 Konzerte. Fettes Brot, Shoutout Lautz und Larue.
Matzen, Jennifer Rostock, Kaija Candela und Gossip. Eine Karte für 10 Konzerte. Nur bei Fritz und nur zu gewinnen.
Immer Montag bis Freitag bei den Radio Fritzen am Nachmittag um 10 nach 3.
Mehr Infos Fritze.
Die Fritz 10 Konzertkarte.
Neues Jahr. Neues Glück. Einen Tag vor der Londoner Afghanistan-Konferenz hat der Bundestag über den deutschen Einsatz am Hindukusch diskutiert. Kanzlerin Merkel sagte in einer Regierungserklärung, Ziel sei es, die Verantwortung für das Land Schritt für Schritt in die Hände der Afghanen zu übergeben. SPD-Chef Gabriel forderte einen konkreten Zeitplan für den Abzug der deutschen Truppen ab 2011. Nur dann würden die Sozialdemokraten einem neuen Afghanistan-Mandat zustimmen. In London kommen morgen Vertreter von 70 Ländern zusammen, um über die Zukunft Afghansans zu beraten. Die internationale Gemeinschaft will dem Jemen stärker wirtschaftlich und politisch helfen. Das ist das Ergebnis einer Konferenz in London, an der Vertreter von rund 20 Staaten und Organisatoren wie der Weltbank teilnahmen. Nach Angaben des britischen Außenministers Milliband wurde ein Fünf-Punkte-Plan vereinbart. Er sieht unter anderem Hilfen bei der Grenzsicherung des Jemen und eine Unterstützung durch den Währungsfonds IWF vor. US-Ausministerin Clinton betonte, ein instabiler Jemen sei eine Gefahr für die ganze Region. Das verarmte Land gilt als Rückzugsgebiet für Mitglieder des Terronetzwerkes Al-Qaeda. Soziale Netzwerke wie Facebook oder StudiVZ sollten noch sicherer werden. Das Bundesverbraucherministerium fordert von den Anbietern, dass Daten von vornherein geblockt werden, damit nicht erst die Nutzer aktiv werden müssen. Außerdem sollten nach Meinung des Ministeriums inhaltende Netzwerke komplett wieder gelöscht werden können. Mehrere soziale Netzwerke hatten im letzten Jahr auf eine Abmahnung der Verbraucherzentralen reagiert und versprochen, mehr für den Datenschutz zu tun. Fußball-Zweitliges Union Berlin muss in den nächsten Spielen auf Abwehrspieler Daniel Schulz verzichten. Er hat sich gestern beim Training den Mittelfingern gebrochen und fällt bis zu zehn Wochen aus. Unionssportdirektor Beek sagte, die erneute Verletzung sei bitter für Schulz, weil er vorher noch lange Knieprobleme gehabt hatte. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Cottbus haben wir minus 6 Grad, in Frankfurt sind es minus 5, in Potsdam und Angermünde minus 4, in Neuropie minus 2, in Wittenberge minus 1 und in Berlin um die minus 4 Grad. Nacht ist bewölkt und schenkt euch bis zu 8 cm Neuschnee. Die Tiefsttemperatur liegt bei minus 7 Grad. Morgen gibt es dann ab und zu Schnee und Graubeschauer. Es wird etwas wärmer als heute und das Ganze bei knapp über 0 Grad. A2 in Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Cäsar und Volinen besteht Gefahr durch ein Defekt des Fahrzeuges, das die rechte Spur blockiert. A10 südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Zwischen 3 Knutetal und Ludwigsfelde West gab es einen Unfall. Hier ist der Standstreifen blockiert. A10 östlicher Berliner Ring Richtung 3 Schwanenbeck. Zwischen 3 Spree und Freienbrink gab es einen Unfall. Hier ist der Standstreifen blockiert. Und Stadtverkehr Berlin A100, A111. Hier ist über noch alles zu. Es gibt immer mal wieder Stau und stockenden Verkehr. Fahrt vorsichtig, da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt. Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt. Die zwei Sprechstunden mit Nico und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club im Chaos Radio und Nico von der Firma Schnee von Morgen, nee von gestern, von übermorgen, von wie war es?
Von morgen natürlich.
Schnee von morgen, natürlich war es Schnee von morgen. Und mir Markus Richter, der sozusagen dafür da ist, die beiden Nerds im Zaum zu halten, wenn ich das mal so formulieren darf. Es geht heute um Cloud Computing. Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde und wir wollten noch mal drüber reden, wie man das Cloud Computing hacken kann. Ich will eine von euch beiden noch mal kurz zusammenfassen. Cloud Computing.
Ich will noch einmal das tolle Zitat von dem Notiz-Zettel hier.
Warte, erst noch mal nur für den Fall, das Leute jetzt gerade erst angemacht haben. Cloud Computing ist?
Die ominöse Wolke im Internet. Software-SS-Service, Dienste, die nicht mehr bei mir selber stattfinden, sondern auf einer fremden skalierbaren Infrastruktur.
Wow, wer es nicht verstanden hat, ruft jetzt an. 0331 77 97 110. Es geht also darum, dass ich mir Rechenleistungen im Netz mieten kann und zwar auch in Höhe von mehreren tausend Computern. Und wir haben uns gerade... Und auch Speicherplatz. Speicherplatz, also quasi ganze Maschinen, die aber gar keine wirklichen Maschinen sind, sondern nur so tun, als wären sie Maschinen. Und wir wollten gerade noch darüber sprechen, wie das aussieht. Das könnte man auch sozusagen sich zu Nutze machen. Eigentlich muss man dafür bezahlen, aber wenn ich es irgendwie schaffe, das zu übernehmen, dann muss ich ja nichts dafür bezahlen. Wie geht das? Und wenn ja, wie? Also ich glaube, dass das viel dramatischere Szenario wäre, wenn ich tatsächlich auch von mir aus auch bezahle dafür und also mittendrin sitze in so einer Cloud und dann da anfange, Daten einzusammeln. Und da gibt es durchaus auch Szenarien, die sind im Moment noch theoretisch. Also das heißt, da sitzen jetzt Leute dran und überlegen sich, okay, ich habe einen virtuellen Server, aber in Wirklichkeit ist es ja schon eine echte physikalische Hardware. Das heißt also, wenn jetzt drei Leute so eine virtuelle Maschine gemietet haben, dann heißt es aber, dass diese drei Leute in Wirklichkeit auf einer echten Maschine sind, die aber einfach durch drei geteilt wird. Das heißt also, da wird einfach die Kapazität der Maschine einfach in drei Kuchenstücke aufgeteilt und die teilen die sich. Aber in Wirklichkeit sind die physikalisch, das heißt, sie benutzen irgendwie die gleiche CPU und den gleichen Arbeitsspeicher und es geht irgendwie alles durch die gleichen Datenleitungen durch, die auf der gleichen Platine in diesem Gerät sind. Und die Frage ist, ob es nicht eine Möglichkeit gibt, irgendwie zu schauen, was tun eigentlich die anderen in ihrem virtuellen System. Das ist so die Fragestellung dabei.
Darf ich ihn jetzt endlich sagen?
Jetzt endlich, los!
Der Satz, der auf dem Zettel steht, heißt Hack one, get ten free. Und der beschreibt natürlich diesen Umstand, dass wenn ich einen Einstiegsweg in diese Cloud-Dienste finde, um Benutzerdaten zu knacken oder um irgendwie auf virtuelle Server rauszukommen, dann ist der natürlich reproduzierbar und ermöglicht mir perspektivisch eine Armada von Rechnern zu übernehmen.
Du hast in deinem Beispiel gesagt, was ist die größte Anzahl an virtuellen Maschinen, die ihr mal hochgefahren habt?
Bei uns waren es, glaube ich, 250. Und für den Otto-Normal-User ist es so, dass wenn man mehr als 20 haben will, muss man einmal eine E-Mail schreiben. Dann kriegt man aber auch sofort mehr.
Okay, aber das heißt sozusagen, in dem Moment, wo bei eurer einen Maschine jemand ein Loch gefunden hätte, hätte er damit auch die restlichen 250 am Start gehabt.
Hätte er ein Loch gefunden, hätte er alle übernehmen können.
Also der Trick dabei ist, dass du nicht in dieser einen speziellen Maschinenloch findest, sondern generell in diesem ganzen System, was diese virtuellen Maschinen eigentlich verwaltet. Also das ist das sogenannte Host-System. Also man unterscheidet bei diesem virtuellen Computing in der Regel zwischen Host-System und Gast-System. Also ein Host ist also das, was ursprünglich auf diesem Computer läuft. Das ist also eigentlich ein System, was nichts anderes macht, als diese virtuellen Maschinen hoch und runter zu fahren. Und das Gast-System, das sozusagen nistet sich als Gast ein, das ist also dein System, was du mietest da drauf. Und der Trick dabei ist jetzt nicht, dieses Gast-System zu knacken, sondern das Host-System. Also das System, das wirklich unten drunter steckt. Und wenn du in diesem Haus bist, kannst du natürlich auch in diese ganzen Gast-Systeme irgendwie reinschauen. Das heißt, es ist nicht nur so, dass ich dann die ganze Rechenleistung des Host-Systems für mich habe, sondern ich kann auch tatsächlich gucken, was machen die Einzelnen? In der Regel ist das sogar die spannende Information. Also ich meine, Rechenleistung kann man halt irgendwie mieten, da weißt du, das kostet 10 Cent pro Stunde. Aber du willst ja eigentlich wissen, was tun die da eigentlich. Also welche Kreditkartendaten werden da gerade verarbeitet? Welche privaten Facebook-Profile werden da gerade verarbeitet? Halt die ganzen spannenden Informationen. Welche E-Mails liegen da? Das heißt, du willst sowohl einerseits schauen, was tun die da? Das heißt, was geht gerade durch diesen virtuellen Prozessor durch? Andererseits willst du auch wissen, was ist auf den virtuellen Festplatten gelagert? Und das ist, ich will nicht sagen, dass es jetzt einfacher ist als bei der klassischen Infrastruktur, aber es ist natürlich schon sehr verlockend, wenn die Sachen alle im Internet sind. Sie sind da erreichbar. Ich kann mich möglicherweise mit einer falschen Identität anmelden. Es ist eine ziemliche Anonymität da, was diesen Anbieter angeht. Und wenn ich dann erst mal auf diesen Kissen bin, kann ich natürlich auch anfangen, da ein bisschen Forschung zu betreiben. Forschung betreiben? Du sagst das gerade schon. Da sitzen gerade Leute dran, um rauszugucken, ob es funktioniert. Gab es da schon Fälle, von denen man weiß? Nee, also die werden auch ziemlich durch die Medien gegangen, wenn da tatsächlich was ist. Es gibt auf jeden Fall Ansätze. Das ist natürlich alles noch ein bisschen, teilweise sehr theoretisch, sehr wissenschaftlich. Man geht auf verschiedene Wege ran. Ich würde aber nicht ausschließen, dass da innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre irgendwas passiert, was das Konzept vielleicht sogar grundsätzlich in Frage stellt. Das ist durchaus denkbar. Es wird sozusagen wie bei der Playstation 3, wo heute der Proof of Concept, der als exploit, wie es so schön heißt, rausgekommen ist. Also man kann die theoretisch hacken, müsst jetzt nur noch jemand so machen, das komfortabel ist. Danach wird bei Cloud Computing noch gesucht nach dem ersten großen Gau. Genau, und man hofft natürlich, dass es denn auch publik wird, wenn es jemand schafft. Der wirklich große Gau ist natürlich, dass es jemand schafft, und es nicht publik wird, sondern es halt einfach so gemacht wird. Und diese Informationen darüber auch in irgendwelchen Kreisen für ziemlich viel Geld gehandelt wird. Das wäre natürlich dann schon ziemlich dramatisch.
Also ich hoffe, dass es keiner schafft.
Ja, aber wie wahrscheinlich ist das, dass es keiner schafft? Tja, da müssen wir jetzt mal in die Glaskugel gucken.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, also die Angriffszenarien, die ich bislang gelesen habe, die sind interessant, aber wie ich finde, bislang noch nicht bedrohlich. Es geht im Kern darum, zuerst eine virtuelle Maschine zu starten, die auf dem gleichen System läuft, wie der, den ich angreifen will. Ein Angriffszenario hat ja irgendwie ein Ziel. Also das heißt, erstmal will ich ja nicht einfach nur beliebig...
Ah, und ich bin der Böse. Ich war nur davon ausgegangen, dass ich mir möglichst billig Rechenleistungen besorgen möchte. Du allerdings, ja?
Sondern das für den Bösen interessante Angriffszenario ist natürlich, wenn ich von jemandem weiß, dass er auf der Cloud läuft, muss ich erstmal in die Nähe seines Hostsystems kommen, physikalisch. Möchte man normal ja an, das geht nicht, weil ich sozusagen gar nicht beeinflussen kann, wie dieser Computer startet. Da gibt es aber inzwischen einen ganz guten Ansatz, also gut, um das zu schaffen. Also um eine Maschine zu starten, die auf der gleichen Infrastruktur läuft, wie das Ziel. Und dann laufen die Angriffszenarien darüber, erstmal überhaupt Netzwerk-Traffic, der auf dem zweiten virtuellen System neben mir liegt, mitzuhören. Und da gibt es inzwischen so eine Art Proof-of-Konzept. Wobei die Virtualisierer, die angesetzt werden, auch sehr unterschiedlich sind. Also Amazon setzt auf Xen, das ist ein Open-Source-Projekt. Mehrere andere setzen auf VM-Ware. Und es gibt einfach auch unterschiedliche Systeme, in dieser Art zu virtualisieren.
Wie erreicht man das, dass man auf demselben System landet, wie der, den ich jetzt ausschnüffeln will?
Übertreint error. Also die Attacke geht einfach tatsächlich darüber, dass man sagt, ich fahre mir ganz viele Rechner hoch, und dann haben sie einen Test geschrieben, wie ich sehr zuverlässig sagen kann, ob ich neben dem anderen liege. Ich glaube, es funktioniert über Hardware-UIDs, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das ist vielleicht nochmal eine ganz andere Sache, die auch noch extrem wichtig ist. Wir haben ja bisher über Sachen gesprochen, oder Nico setzt jetzt diese Virtualisierung ein, um Sachen darauf zu berechnen, die wahrscheinlich sowieso früher oder später im Internet landen, also die relativ öffentlich sind. Problematisch wird es natürlich für Firmen, die da auch private Daten oder nicht öffentliche Daten dann in diese Cloud auslagern wollen. Also klassischer Fall wäre jetzt ein Versicherungskonzern, das ganze IT bei uns im Keller verbraucht nur Strom, und irgendwie haben wir keine Lust mehr. Wir lagern uns jetzt in die Cloud, und wir mieten jetzt einfach ein paar virtuelle Server. Und dann haben wir natürlich ganz neue Probleme, was jetzt einmal diese rechtliche Situation angeht. Weil natürlich diese Cloud, haben wir ja gesagt, ist eine ganz diffuse Sache. Das heißt, wir wissen möglicherweise gar nicht mehr, in welchem Land diese Server stehen. Stehen sie in Deutschland, stehen sie irgendwo in der EU, in Europa, stehen sie in den USA, in Asien, China vielleicht. Das ist alles durchaus denkbar mit so einer Cloud. Und da haben wir das Problem, dass ich als Firma dann eigentlich nicht mehr wirklich Herr über diese Daten bin. Das heißt, die liegen dann irgendwo, und ich hab wahrscheinlich auch das Versprechen von dem Anbieter, dass niemand anderes auf diese Daten zugreift. Letztendlich gibt es natürlich aber nie eine Garantie, dass zum Beispiel diese Festplatten irgendwann mal, wenn sie dann, sag ich mal, verbraucht sind, oder nach einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren, wenn sie gelaufen sind, dass die irgendwann einfach rausgezogen werden im laufenden Betrieb und dann irgendwo der Entsorgung zugeführt werden. Das heißt, da gibt es dann Leute, die dann irgendwie gerne diese Festplatten entgegennehmen und gucken, was man vielleicht von diesen Daten noch runterkratzen könnte. Und das ist natürlich schon ein Szenario, wenn ich als Firma wirklich heikle, sensible Daten verarbeite, aber eigentlich nicht mehr dieses System vollständig unter Kontrolle habe. Dann muss ich einfach auch schauen, welche gesetzlichen Regelungen gelten. Kann ich das als Firma überhaupt machen, meine IT auslagern, irgendwo anders hin in eine Cloud? Das heißt, ich muss also irgendwie auch schauen, ein gewisses Vertragsverhältnis haben. Ich muss gucken, ob es mir die Regelungen nach dem deutschen Datenschutzgesetz überhaupt erlauben, diese Sachen einfach so rauszugeben. Gibt es eine vertragliche Vereinbarung mit dem Anbieter? Bei vielen wichtigen Daten in Deutschland ist es so, dass sie also nicht aus der EU rausgehen dürfen. Also ich muss dann wirklich auch einen Anbieter nehmen, der mir garantiert, dass diese Sachen in der EU bleiben, weil man einfach sagt, in der EU gibt es einigermaßen halbwegs zuverlässige Datenschutzstandards. In der USA sind diese Datenschutzstandards möglicherweise nicht mehr gegeben. Und dann ist noch die Frage, gibt es denn vielleicht irgendwelche Geheimdienste oder Ermittlungsbehörden, die sagen, ja, wir wollen jetzt aber wirklich mal darauf gucken. Dann habe ich natürlich bei uns in Deutschland oder in der EU eine ganz andere rechtliche Möglichkeit dagegen vorzugehen, in den USA oder China, Israel oder sowas. Wir wollen jetzt eine Festplatte haben, es gibt gar keine Diskussion. Und dann habe ich als Firma, die für diese Daten eigentlich verantwortlich ist, natürlich auch kaum noch eine Handhabe dagegen. Und dann sind diese Daten schon irgendwie weg oder sind dann halt irgendwo anders. Das heißt also, wenn ich selber so eine Firma gründen will, dann sollte ich mal gefälligst gucken, wo das dann hingeht. Wenn ich so einen Service nutzen will tatsächlich, kann ich das denn als User irgendwie rausfinden, wenn ich jetzt so eine Firma gebe. Ich würde jetzt gerne mal wissen, was für eine Infrastruktur die nutzt. Gibt es da Quellen? Kann man das selber irgendwo nachgucken, wo deren Server dann letztendlich stehen? Nee, das ist schwierig. Also wenn der Anbieter da nicht ganz konkret antwortet, dann habe ich eigentlich kaum einen Weg, das rauszufinden. Also dann müsste ich da höchstens auch auf die Datenschutzbehörden vertrauen. Also wenn sich ein Anbieter weigert zu sagen, wo er seine Server zu stehen hat oder ob er sie vielleicht virtualisiert hat, dann gibt es natürlich die Möglichkeit, mal auch den Datenschutzbeauftragten anzusprechen. Also die Firma, die macht hier irgendwie so ein Geheimnis daraus. Wollen Sie vielleicht mal nachschauen gehen? Dann kann der natürlich mal zu der Firma gehen, sagen, wo ist denn hier euer Server? Die will ich jetzt gerne mal sehen. Die sind in der Cloud. Was gibt es denn da für Verträge? Wo stehen die denn? Welche Sicherheitsvorkehrungen habt ihr getroffen? Und möglicherweise ist dann sogar auch ein Bußgeld fällig für die Firma. Das kann auch passieren. Wer hat diese Daten dann unüberlegt irgendwo hin auslagert in die Cloud und sich da auch keine Gedanken über irgendwelche juristischen Beschränkungen gemacht hat? Das ist aber sozusagen eher das große Schutz für den alltäglichen Gebrauch nicht wirklich irgendwie praktikabel. Also ich will ja nicht jedes Mal, wenn ich mich irgendwo auf eine Webseite anmelde, zum Datenschutzbeauftragten gehen. Das ist dann quasi schon eher Aktivismus als tatsächlich praktikabel. Aber da muss man jetzt leben. Wie ist es denn überhaupt, du hast das vorhin schon mal die Glaskugel erwähnt, wo geht das jetzt hin? Was kommt als nächstes mit dem Cloud Computing? Wird das so weitergehen, dass du einfach sagen immer mehr, immer besser im Netz? Oder wird es dann mal einen Umschwung geben? Gibt es da schon was abzusehen? Also ich denke, dass gerade bei der Verfügbarkeit wird es für Firmen spannend. Also auch wirklich für ernsthafte Anwendungen. Also werde ich wirklich als Firma auf diese Systeme angewiesen bin, dass sie da sind, dass sie funktionieren, dass sie auch mit einer gewissen Performance arbeiten. Das heißt, dass ich einfach eine bestimmte Rechenleistung ganz sicher zur Verfügung habe. Das kann ich eigentlich nur machen, wenn ich dieses Rechenzentrum selbst betreibe oder wenn ich die Server selbst betreibe und wirklich im Keller vor mir zu stehen habe. Also ich bin da sehr skeptisch, was wirklich, ich sag mal, unternehmenskritische Anwendungen angeht. Also ich würde mir vielleicht widersprechen. Aber wenn ich jetzt wirklich absolut 100 Prozent garantieren muss, also wie so Sachen wie jetzt hier im Rundfunk, im Fernsehen, das ist ein klassischer Fall, wo einfach auch Kraftwerke einfach ganz konservativ sagen, also da darf es keinen Ausfall geben, da gibt es keine Ausrede, sondern es muss einfach funktionieren. Punkt. Und das sind einfach klassische Sachen, die kann ich nicht in die Cloud geben. Und ich denke mal, dass es möglicherweise auch, wenn der Trend weiter anhält und wenn man Sachen in die Cloud geht, die Anbieter aber nicht entsprechend nachrüsten und aufstocken, dann wird es da auch vielleicht zu einem Engpass geben, was dann vielleicht auch wieder Leute dazu bewegen könnte, nachzudenken, ob das jetzt eine richtige Entscheidung war. Wir hatten was Ähnliches beim Outsourcing, es war auch eine große Welle vor ein paar Jahren, alles nach Indien, alles nach Indien. Und jetzt merken die Firmen, aber das bringt eigentlich nicht so viel und jetzt geht auch ganz wieder viel zurück davon. Es war auch so ein typischer Hype. Ja, es ist jetzt wirklich ein Glaskugelschauen. Wahrscheinlich wird sich diese Cloud Computing-Geschichte halten, weil diese Virtualisierungslösungen funktionieren alle auch schon recht gut, von ein paar Kleinigkeiten abgesehen. Und möglicherweise ist es ja auch ein Weg und ein Mittel, um den wachsenden Stromverbrauch irgendwie einigermaßen in Grenzen zu kriegen, der durch die IT entsteht. Cloud Computing kann man nicht für kritische Strukturen benutzen. Das hört sich für mich an, wie wenn ich eine Firma neu grinde, dann mach ich erst mal Cloud Computing, weil es billig ist. Wenn da Kram wirklich nicht funktionieren muss, dann sollte ich danach denken, mir die Server wieder hinzustellen. Wenn ich auch absehen kann, dass der Service auch gut läuft und ich die Server auch wirklich brauche. Und dann vielleicht nochmal für Last-Spitzen, um wirklich irgendwelche kurzzeitigen Sachen abzufackeln, eine Werbekampagne oder sowas, dann kann ich ja immer noch welche dazu nehmen. Das ist, es scheint mir ziemlich viel Technik zu sein, dass man sagt, naja, funktioniert irgendwie, kann man benutzen, aber wenn es kritisch wird, dann lieber selber machen. Könnte man das so zusammenfassen, dein Blick auf Cloud Computing? Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe einfach keine Garantie, dass es wirklich 100% funktioniert. Das habe ich jetzt bei eigenen Server nicht, aber da kann ich wenigstens den... Selber schuld sein... .denn mich selber schuld, genau.
Also ich würde dir gerne einmal die Gegenposition ergreifen. Also um selber einmal die Glaskugel reinzublicken. Ich glaube, dass wir wirklich erwarten eine sehr strenge Diskussion, wo es um Datensicherheit, wo es um Datenschutz geht, wo es um diese Diskussion geht. Meine Fotos liegen auf Flickr, meine Videos liegen auf YouTube, meine Identität im weitesten Sinne liegt auf Facebook, meine täglichen Status-Updates liegen irgendwie auf Twitter. Was bedeutet das mit diesen Daten? Was bedeutet Privatsphäre da drin? Das werden wir erwarten, das wird eine Bremse sein. Ich glaube, dass es für Unternehmen in Zukunft Cloud Computing quasi unumgänglich ist. Ich glaube, dass alle dorthin wechseln werden. Ich glaube, dass dieser Zuverlässigkeitsgedanke heute schon, wenn man einfach unter den Strich schaut und guckt, welche Infrastruktur einfach verlässlicher ist, dann haben sich die großen Cloud Computing Dienste einfach als wahnsinnig schlagkräftig herausgestellt. In solchen Fällen wie Kraftwerken, unternehmenskritische Daten setzt sich inzwischen der Trend durch, das auch im Cloud Computing zu machen, aber die Cloud selber zu betreiben. Also das heißt zu sagen, ich nutze nicht diese Infrastruktur, die auf Servern irgendwo auf der Welt steht. Wenn ich eine große deutsche Bank bin, dann will ich meine Kundendaten nicht auf der Welt verstreut, auf Festplatten haben, die ich nicht in der Kontrolle habe. Aber ich möchte dieses System nutzen, die Art und Weise, wie die Computer miteinander kommunizieren, diese Art und Weise der Virtualisierung. Und ich wäre blöd, mir so ein System nicht selber aufzusetzen. Das heißt, ich glaube, die Tage, wo der Computer physisch im Rack drin steht und nur diese eine Aufgabe hat, diesen glaube ich gezählt.
Okay, das heißt, man kann das weiter nutzen. Aber wie gesagt, bei kritischen Sachen sollte man vorsichtig sein. Was mich jetzt noch mal interessieren würde, ich bin ja eher so ein, kann man sagen, Aushilfsnörd. Ich betreibe halt, ich habe auch so selber Web-Space und mache das auch selber. Wann wird das oder ab wann lohnt es sich, dass ich selber eingehe und sage so, ich möchte jetzt so eine kleine Cloud-Instanz für mich haben? Dann nimmst du einfach einen Taschenrechner und guckst mal nach, was dich dieser klassische Web-Space kostet und guckst nach, was sich so eine Cloud-Instanz kostet im Monat. Aber Cloud und sagen heißt auf jeden Fall, ich muss mich selber kümmern. Also da kriege ich quasi so eine Maschine angeboten, die muss ich dann selber bestücken. Richtig, du fängst wirklich mit einer leeren Festplatte an, virtuellen Festplatte. Kannst du denn in der Regel eine Installations-CD aussuchen, ob du da jetzt ein Linux oder ein Windows-System drauf haben willst. Und dann spielst du das da ein, fängst mit einem leeren System an und musst dann ganz klassisch erstmal die Software installieren, Passwörter einrichten, User einrichten und sowas. Es gibt ja ganz gute fertigen Sachen. Also du kannst sagen, du kannst irgendwie einen Drupal-CMS, einen Content-Management-System haben oder willst du irgendwie einen Video-Server haben. Das bieten einige der Anbieter mittlerweile fertig an. Das ist ja nur noch... Das ist ein bisschen aber auch teurer, ne? Nö. Also von der Computing-Zeit her ist es das gleiche. Was teilweise ein bisschen teurer ist, ist wenn du Windows-Systeme hast. Was dann einfach daran liegt, dass auch die Lizenzkosten dafür schon drin sind, wenn ich es richtig sehe.
Im Übrigen ein interessantes Cloud-Problem, dass Software-Lizenzen heute ja meist an die Installation oder den Prozessor gebunden sind.
Also das Windows selbst auch schon, ja.
Genau, und die Lizenzgeber tatsächlich schwere Probleme haben, sich an diese Cloud zu gewöhnen und zu sagen, was ist eine Lizenz in Zeitaltern dieser schwammigen Grenzen? Es gibt da neue Lizenzierungsmodelle, also Oracle hat eins draußen, Browser Streaming Server, Adobe. Also es gibt sozusagen Lizenzierungsmodelle dafür, aber es kommt sehr zaghaft.
Hast du da selber schon mal Probleme mit gehabt?
Nee, wir haben tatsächlich schnell eine Lösung gefunden, aber das hätte ein großes Problem für uns sein können.
Okay, Lizenzierungsprobleme gibt es also auch noch. Wir haben ziemlich viel gelernt heute über Cloud Computing hier im Chaos Radio auf Ritz, Frank Rosengard und Nico... Oh Gott, jetzt hab ich den Nachnamen vergessen. Nico Longolius. Vielen Dank euch beiden. Noch letzte Hörer, sowas wie immer Backups machen. Herrgott, zum Beispiel auch von meiner Sprechfähigkeit. Wollt ihr da noch was loswerden? Also eine gute Idee ist ein Backup, einfach auf nächstes Jahr eine Festplatte zu machen, vielleicht sogar zu verschlüsseln und irgendwie einem guten Kumpel in die Hand zu drücken, dass es aus der Wohnung raus ist.
Für die meisten User ist der Satz, einen Backup haben ist schon toll. Ich glaube, die meisten User da draußen haben nach gar keins. Eins ist schon verdammt gut.
Einen Backup sollt ihr also jedenfalls haben. Das gilt auch nach zwei Stunden Cloud Computing im Chaos Radio auf Ritz. Und immer gut das Internet in Schuss halten, sonst bringt die Cloud nichts. Das stimmt. Und hier kommen jetzt, ich hoffe, sie haben es gut durch die Cloud da draußen geschafft, Smith und Smart, die euch im Night Flight mit Mash-Ups erfreuen werden. Wahrscheinlich blutet euch danach das Ohr, aber es lohnt sich. Hier gibt es wie immer zum Abschluss vom Chaosradio von Trekkie Birthday. Web-Side.